When it's time to celebrate with fireworks,
you could just buy them, or you could improvise
and make your own. In this project, we're
making these hand-held sparklers, that will
burn for up to a minute, and cost less than
a penny each.
For this project, make sure you have some
clothes pins, some safety goggles, and a thick
pair of gloves. We're gonna be making some simple hand-held sparklers, that are just
dangerous enough, to add a little pyrotechnic
thrill to your next celebration. You may notice
these sparkle sticks, are almost exactly the
same, as the slow burning fuses that we made
in a different project. We used those to ignite
some homemade smoke flares, which you can
see in another project video. Alright, to
get started, let's pour 60 mL of water, into
a pan set on medium heat. This white powder,
is a mixture of 36 grams KNO3, and 24 grams
of white table sugar. With hot water and a
little bit of mixing, the powder should dissolve
completely. Next we can mix in a few drops
of food coloring, and I chose to use 7 drops
of red. At this point we're ready to add around
12 feet of 100% cotton yarn, and this will
need a couple of minutes to soak up the liquid.
When the yarn is super saturated, let's transfer
it to a cookie sheet in a zig-zag pattern
so it's all evenly spaced. Now this goes in
an oven set to 150ºC for about 20 minutes.
And at the 10 minute mark, it's a good idea
to slide a spatula, under the yarn to lift
it up, and help prevent it from baking to
the cookie sheet. Remember that this is extremely
flammable and very dangerous, so make sure
you use extreme caution, and have a fire extinguisher
close by. Alright, our time is up, so we can
remove the tray from the oven, and leave it
to cool for another 5-10 minutes. You can
see that when the yarn has cooled, it's fairly
stiff, and holds it's shape. To finish these
up, all we need to do is snip the ends with
a pair of scissors, and these sparklers are
ready to use. I went ahead and made a couple
more batches in festive colors, just for fun.
Let's test this one out, by placing it in
the end of a clothespin, just like this. When
you light your sparkler, you'll see it smoke
quite a bit, and throw off a beautifully dangerous
array of sparks. The sparks are pretty hot,
and they can burn you, so make sure this is
done with adult supervision. You can use one
sparkle stick to light another very quickly,
and of course your clothespin holders can
be used over and over again. In my experience,
this is a cheap, and gratifying way to share
a little excitement, and wonder, on these
special occasions. The best part is, you can
make hundreds of them for just a few dollars.
Well there's how to make some improvised hand-held
fireworks for your next celebration. If you
liked this project, perhaps you'll like some
of my others. Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com